Iranian protesters don't know if the
person standing next to them is with
them
or about to abduct them
there's often been a heavy and visible
security Presence at protest as the
regime tries to maintain control
but plain clothes police are also
operating stealing people off the street
the city of Courage has seen some of the
fiercest protests
they've taken place near a university
and the protesters are young this is
where a woman is abducted from the
streets and our analysis shows how
security forces are operating
it's a busy street in broad daylight and
secret police are trying to force a
woman into their car
[Music]
amid the chaos one of them reaches into
a pocket and pulls a gun
an onlooker attempts to intervene before
being chased away at gunpoint
[Applause]
this yellow box is around the driver
look carefully he's pointing an
anti-riot gun at anyone watching
the woman is bundled into the back seat
we don't know her fate
another clip shows the scene just
moments later
a young woman without a hijab can be
seen running away
we know it's the same place because the
shop front and the white van match the
previous video
so who are the men hiding in plain sight
this is a video filmed before the
abduction we see a gray Peugeot 405
experts tell us this is a favored ride
for Iranian intelligence agents
the man in the red shirt behind the
wheel is the same as the man brandishing
the anti-riot gun earlier and we can see
that the other men in this video are the
same men seen bundling the unknown woman
into the car
one of them is carrying a radio look at
his right hand these agents were not
here by coincidence this is exactly
atmosphere that you don't know who this
guy is you know you you cannot trust him
and that's why he's starting and you
know the process is difficult difficult
and dangerous
this is a pattern repeating across Iran
often brutally
social media accounts are even sharing
tips on how to identify potential
abductors
one warned protesters to look out for
people wearing shoulder bags as in this
clip
[Applause]
tremendous risk the protesters run
they may not be able to fully trust the
crowd so they trust the cause instead
Tom Cheshire Sky News